certo è che ce l'ho ancora ma in realtà
l'ho tolto mesi fa altro che ho
registrato questo video sempre mentre
volgesse so che sono arrivano miliardo
di commenti ma non l'avevi tolta l'ho
tolto solo che un video registrato prima
fine della parentesi bella a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti avessero video sono
fa vj e oggi siamo su wonju reder che
vuol dire deriva da un giro che
significa quale delle due preferisci c'è
una scelta che bisogna fare è che tra
queste due cose ad esempio è simile al
gioco che avevo fatto già un paio di
mesi fa però lì c'era una scelta sola
bisognava rispondere sì o no invece qua
ci sono due scelte c'è bisogna
sceglierne una per forza la prima scelta
di oggi ragazzi e saresti capace di
volare oppure essere capace a respirare
sott'acqua
io direi di capaci di volare infatti a
un certo tutti quasi tutti quello che le
concetto ad acqua probabilmente erano
delle sirene o in quel preciso momento
stavano affogando quindi dovevano
rispondere in fretta preferiresti
perderti nel bosco di notte o rimanere
intrappolato in una casa abbandonata a
madonna che sia difficile ragazzi perché
nel bosco c'è un lander me nella casa
abbandonata c'è mia nonna che mi rifila
della sagne preferirei zoolander man
infatti tutti al 100 sneijder è che il
caso nappi alaska non è più figo questo
dell'altro so perché mi piace di più
preferiresti essere più grande cantante
nel mondo ma brutto o il peggiore
cantante nel mondo ma bello ma io sono
già il peggiore cantante nel mondo però
sono un gran figo quindi che cazzo ne
frega a me ma justin bieber
quale di queste due centrale lorenzo già
mi chiamano nei commenti e renzoni v è
sexy
e vabbè grazie walsingham è infatti
scelto tutti the works singer e feriti
combattere gli zombies un drago mentre
usi una balestra la madonna o combattere
gli zombie con quattro gorilla
a me fanno cagare lo rimandiamo per la
dragon dragon tutti di skyrim
preferiresti baciare un vagabondo
leccare il piede di porco di qualcuno
vagabondo magari ci sono delle vagabondi
gnocche che non sai hanno certo stile
vagabond se non avessi scelta cosa
preferiresti tra ucciderti oppure far
entrare il tuo fratellino degli hunger
games ma se il mio fratellino è più o
meno come me quindi so che spaccherebbe
il cool in e gli hunger games quindi
hunger games cosa preferiresti tra
l'essere in galera per un anno o vivere
completamente isolato nelle montagne per
un anno
però se vivono le montagne non c'è il
wifi in galera c'è il wifi quindi cazzo
montagne galera death of anger abbiamo
un appuntamento con topanga da boy meets
world
non ho mai visto steve lanciarsi oppure
pam da the office ma in cessa pedali a
non scherzare quella era una foto brutta
e gioca pure questa dapprima tutta la
vita come a caso il 10 ha scelto quella
dei scemi o no sto scherzando
io non ci vedo ultimamente ho perso dei
decimi non voglio neanche spiegarvi il
perché ma potete immaginarlo in realtà
si scopre che sono due trans e
travestiti però preferiresti vive nel
passato vivere nel futuro e questa è una
bella domanda me la supposta un sacco di
volte rendo il futuro sono futuristico
rap futuristico futuro questi tutti
futuro strano è perché la tal futura una
merda proferì lessi smettere di usare
youtube smettere di usare facebook
ovviamente smettere di usare facebook
che sono come cazzo di farci i video a
tutti hanno scelto sme ma veramente
pensavo che tutti dicessero [ __ ]
youtube invece facebook odiatissimo a
basso zuckerberg preferiresti passare
una giornata con justin bieber o con
gamer come cassano hanno scritto justin
bieber complimenti per aver scritto
blair nel modo più sbagliato del del
mondo trascorrere una giornata con miley
cyrus allora tempo fa io ero un fan
della madonna
diana montario e labico guardava hannah
montana non mi prendete per il culo
lo guardavo che cielo va però miley non
mi piace quindi già si vive ma cosa ma
non è vero ma perché majlis è tagliato i
capelli non è perché lecca le cose fotte
sega può anche le carni microfono quando
mangi maccheroni al formaggio
preferiresti usare il cucchiaio la
forchetta ma chi cazzo magi maccheronico
il cucchiaio e 165mila ce la fate lega a
sto punto usate le bacchette dei cinesi
e giocare nella cacca del cane o severe
nello riina calda di qualcuno e lo
faccio già c'è mi siedo nell'urina per
divertimento quindi l'urina e invece
qualcuno aveva scelto anche il cane
cazzo preferiresti dormire tre ore al
giorno dormire 15 ore al giorno zio
io già dormo 15 ore al giorno che cazzo
voi preferirei 15 per come sono fatto io
pazzi maniaci vade retro ragazzi se
fossi intrappolato in una gabbia
preferiresti essere intrappolato con una
tigre affamata o essere intrappolato con
uno scoiattolo rabbioso scoiattolo e
caccia tigre a the hindu dire
addomesticata non è affamata giusto sono
scemo io no ho sfogliato al massimo
schiaccia la pedata vuol cazzo vorresti
mangiare hamburger per il resto della
tua vita zio io mangio fissa tutti i
giorni viene a [ __ ] pizza tutta la
vita come preferiresti morire mica che
che gioia oggi ore ferirsi morire di
freddo o bruciato fino alla morte a
madonna freeze perché a me non senti più
un calcio dovuto non senti più un cazzo
quindi freeze preferiresti perdere la
testa già quella non ce l'ha ora non
leggo neanche l'altro sono già pazzo io
quindi break è di tutti pazzi per far
passare la rabbia preferiresti lasciare
il computer con una mazza da baseball
una chitarra al pavimento quando gioca
che mario preferisco la mazza da
baseball credimi mi piaci 4 50 se
potesse andare indietro nel tempo e
firmare la dichiarazione d'indipendenza
preferiresti firmare col tuo vero nome o
firmare con uno pseudonimo ridicolo ma
anzi io firmo tipo fa vj quindi
pseudonimo ridicolo preferiresti sempre
indossare le crocs o indossare le calze
coi sandali che avesse difficile che fa
cagare tutte e due le crocs prole odio
allo stesso tempo
fatti sono tutti suoi sandali
preferiresti essere john lennon paul
mccartney ma direi paul mccartney ma non
per la bravura artistica ma per la
durata di vita proprio c'era questa fama
come preferiresti essere attraente ma
essere preso a pugni
ogni mattina perché essere queste
stronzate per ora ma facciamo b
extractive essi dire sì a tutto o no a
tutto ora non lo so zio dipende perché
se mi chiedono vorrei farti un branco di
scimmie magari dovrei dire no quindi a
questo punto diciamo no però ci potrebbe
essere selena gomez a propormi un
appuntamento romantico e direi no vada
per le scimmie preferireste essere il
miglior amico di harry potter o il
miglior amico di katniss everdeen questa
è veramente difficile ve lo dico per
over stavolta vada per harry perché
harry è mio amico in realtà non lo saprò
il mi ami definirsi romperti una gamba
romperti il braccio vada per la gamba
preferiresti avere paparazzi che ti
seguono
no ma io non c'e no paparazzi che mi
seguono figura luridi rivelare un
segreto di te stesso in una giornata il
giornale di settimanale paparazzi
preferiresti essere tanto ciccione o
tanto cappellone guardano non fatto sta
scelta ma me l'hanno appioppata però
amen
allora ragazzi che ho quello che
l'episodio è stato strano perché diverso
da quello di prima ma è veramente figo
lo stesso quindi spero vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi fatemi sapere se volete altri
episodi di questo perché a me piace un
sacco poi non so se a voi ha fatto
cagare
fatemi sapere però che vi sia piaciuto
questo video che uno strumento è un mi
piace ha già pace di facebook e come
video trattando iscrizione cesare si
rischia felici vediamo il prossimo vita
dei ragazzi